this isn't right
it can't be mandated this freedom of
choice freedom of information
we're a free country here
we don't need somebody like trudeau out
there telling you
you have to take it or else and calling
us names
putting us down calling his races i am
by no means a racist i am not a
misogynist i am none of them above
okay not a hard worker
a house and a mortgage to pay
we're
we're in this for
we're a free country here you can't have
people trudeau or whatever telling you
that you have to take this or else
right that's not freedom okay please
that is not freedom
okay
we're a free country here
[Applause]
you know if you want to take a vaccine
or whatever you want to call it go ahead
but you can't force me to okay i don't
think that's right that's not freedom
[Music]
i just should come here and just show
love and respect for canada and our
country and just gather as a people and
unify when we've been so divided by our
own government and everything and
um i think it just showed solidarity for
everyone that's
given so much to the pandemic loss of
jobs people that have had hardships and
everything and lost people to the
pandemic as well as effects of it such
as the lockdowns with mental health
issues
just come together and say this is
enough
um me personally i
haven't had as much as most people i
stand up for the little guys so i look
at this as
what do my kids and my grandkids are
gonna have to do if they don't have can
do that are they gonna have the right to
choose medical freedom are they gonna
have the debt issues that we've had and
the economic issues that we've had are
gonna have for years to come due to this
pandemic
and yeah so it's
that's more or less my
time but i've watched so many people
friends and family lose jobs because
they're choosing of their choice which
it isn't a choice it's
how is it a choice when it's saying
if you don't do what we say
then you don't get to work you don't get
to feed your family
that's not a choice that's an ultimatum
i'm here to get
the freedom back the freedoms that all
canadians should have
we all
know how to make right decisions
on our own
and we don't need the government to
overleach to tell us what to do we
we want good for all of us
and i want good to my children and i
want to make a wise decision about the
future i don't want to make any rare
decisions that somebody is pushing me
too
so i'm here for for all canadians
vaccinated not vaccinated i want us all
united
i want us all
back and free
and i want us to be proud again
this is a tiny fraction of a fraction of
what's out there we know they don't
represent then over 90 percent of
and and protesters who actually have
been vaccinated so let's not give them
too much attention i'm deeply concerned
about the media attention that these
individuals are actually receiving this
is not a one to one this is a 99 to 1.
that's what we're dealing with everybody
cares about the same thing people want
to see healthcare being delivered when
it's needed where it's needed
you know the thought that we would
actually block hospital row in toronto
is to me absolutely shocking this is not
what we do in canada it's it is
bordering on criminal that said i do not
believe in the divisive nature of this
there are many reasons why people want
not to get vaccinated and we shouldn't
we shouldn't vilify them for those views
this is not about a divisive part
[Music]
[Music]